g.
One of the things we wonder about is does
Donald Trump know he lost and he's pretending
to have one for optics or to keep raising
money from his followers?
Or does he actually think he is the rightful
winner of the twenty twenty presidential election?
I actually believe that may be the wrong question.
People like Donald Trump, narcissists with
delusions of grandeur and a complete inability
to self reflect.
They hold contradictory beliefs at the same
time, or sometimes they switch or radically
every 30 seconds between one belief and its
opposite.
CNN is now reporting that Donald Trump has
told some advisers that he is simply going
to refuse to physically leave the White House
on Joe Biden's inauguration day, January 20th.
Aides report being alarmed by Donald Trump,
saying, I'm just not leaving because, as you
can imagine, Secret Service escorting a president
out of the White House would be fascinating,
but it would not exactly do wonders for Donald
Trump's legacy.
But then after saying I'm not leaving, Trump
reportedly kind of walks it back and starts
talking about who he wants to pardon on the
way out and looking forward to just heading
down to Florida, seemingly recognizing that
he did lose and he will leave.
Now, I'm not surprised by this.
The discussion about does Trump know he lost
or not?
This is exactly.
The type of thing I would expect where one
second he's insisting I'm not going to leave
because I won and the next second he's talking
about, screw this, I'm out of here, I'll go
play golf, give me a list of pardons to sign
off on.
There's nothing at all shocking or unusual
about that for someone of Trump's personality
and disposition.
The other funny thing is that at this point,
I believe that most of the people convinced
that Trump did actually win and Joe Biden
stole it, recognize that unless you get some
legal determination to overturn the election,
Trump can't just sort of stay at the White
House like a squatter.
That that's not going to be the way it works.
I think even the people convinced Trump did
win know that unless you get some a court
or a state to overturn a result, you can't
just sit at the White House.
They know even that's not going to work.
And in all seriousness, I would be willing
to pay money to see Donald Trump dragged out
by Secret Service.
But ultimately, it's not going to happen.
And Trump may even end up vacating the White
House this month.
There are rumors, speculation that he'll head
to Florida around Christmas or after, even
though we go back and forth on Trump's going
to do Christmas at the White House, or maybe
not, we don't know.
Trump may leave the White House later this
month and not even come back, or maybe he
will and he'll be convinced by someone around
him.
You know, you should really be there on January
20th.
I don't know.
There would be nothing better for ratings.
There would be nothing better for shock value.
There would be nothing better for comedy than
Trump being physically removed from the White
House.
But it would be a disaster for the country,
and I don't think it's actually going to come
to that now.
In the meantime, prepare yourselves for a
flurry of pardons.
Donald Trump is getting endless requests.
He's regularly asking people around him, should
I pardon this person?
Should I pardoned that person?
What about this one?
People are skipping the normal process normally
to ask for a pardon.
You go through the Justice Department's pardon
attorney with Trump.
Everything is insane.
Everything is childish, everything is unorganized.
And so people are calling Jared Kushner.
They're emailing Trump's chief of staff, Mark
Meadows.
If they have a direct line to Trump, they're
just asking Trump.
It's like a feeding frenzy of people asking
for pardons.
And what's interesting about that is even
though there is a formal process for asking
for a pardon, in theory, anyone who knows
this administration knows that with Trump,
it's who can get in front of Trump when he's
paying attention for 30 seconds and maybe
get him to sign off.
That's the way it works.
And they're completely right.
Their instinct is exactly right.
So we'll see how the pardons go.
But Donald Trump will leave.
And in preparation for Trump leaving and Joe
Biden coming in on January 1st, we are doing
a one day huge membership special.
If you've been thinking about signing up,
if you are sort of ready to make the commitment
to being a member, get on our mailing list,
the David Pakman dotcom.
And then on January 1st, an email will go
out which will tell you here is how to take
advantage of this borderline illegal and certainly
immoral membership special that will be themed
based on the date.
It will be one one twenty one and the membership
special will be themed on that basis.
OK, sign up for the newsletter David Pakman
Dotcom on New Year's Day.
We will let you know how to avail yourself
of that special.
And of course, let me know what you expect
between now and January 20th from Donald Trump.
I'm on Twitter
at David Pakman